can you do it from your laptop
wait it's working hold on what's going
on
i think it's working
test test all right i think i have audio
now
i don't know that was weird okay guys
give me those thumbs ups
and we're getting right into this
hey there we go all right
jeez what a way to start a stream huh
apologies i don't know
what i don't know what happened there
um all right sweet
okay we should be back sorry we're back
hello hi
uh all right
we've done it we've done it
let's just get right into it guys um we
got questions this is a q a
so let's get some questions going um
i'll leave it
i'll leave it to you guys first i have a
list of questions compiled
um but let's let's see it here
first question out go ahead and ask ask
away
go ahead and add me here in the live
feed and
i'll answer the one that uh you know
that i feel like answering
and i'll probably go back and forth to
like the list that i have typed out
um but my goodness
thanks for thanks for joining guys
appreciate you
yeah it's been um it's been a good week
been a busy week
we're cranking on tactical three loads
over at corridor
um so we've been doing a lot of vfx
and basically getting the vfx set up and
ready to go
um so that's been my week but hey just
as a quick
um rules and regulations for the chat if
you guys are spamming anything
then i'm probably gonna have to boot you
um just because we don't we ain't got
time for that you know what i mean we
just don't have time
all right here here here comes questions
um where will you
be in five years um
lots of questions what got you
interested in video editing and
production um let's start with that
let's start with the origin story what
got me interested in video editing and
production
okay so that is a question by
uh joji jojitopic
what got me interested in video editing
and production okay
so um as
a kid i was always very
uh artistic and creative i loved drawing
from like every every time i had a
chance to choose an elective
in middle school i think it started in
middle school when you could choose
electives
i always chose art i loved creating
things
my dad actually introduced me to legos
when i was really young
so i had you know that kind of creative
background with like the legos and
everything we would
follow instructions we would build our
own things and i think that's really
where it started was like
was legos to be honest with me or to be
honest with you guys
um and then from there when it came to
actually like video editing and
production
my friend bobby this was when i was this
is when i was living
in chino hills california um
i i didn't know how they cut from one
image to another
in a movie you know or uh
on tv it didn't make sense to me so i
asked my friend bobby who had a video
camera
hey um how does this work
and he pulled out his video camera and
he filmed over here he rolled over here
and he cut
and then he filmed over here and rolled
over here and then he cut
and he played back and you see the image
go from one
image to another on the live playback
and i was like what
that is the most insane thing i've ever
seen in my whole life
i need to know more so from that moment
is when i got really intrigued
specifically with like a video editing
um that got me started so bobby was the
one
um who got me started
and that's actually when when i uh
when i have like cbe films right that's
like my
random made up production thing um that
stands for clinton bobby and edgar
so bobby is the guy who showed me the
film camera or the video camera edgar is
another good friend of mine who
we just you know we made little dumb
videos together
um so that's kind of what yeah that's
kind of where it took off
um bobby told me that i had windows
movie maker on my computer
and i could edit videos for free so
i was like oh my god i have this
software on my computer that i can use
for free to make short films
absolutely i'm so down so we did a
little test like
we did a fight scene where bobby tries
to trip me
so like we're fighting up here and then
he showed me how to cut right so i was
like oh that's crazy so let's
let's do a cut where like you try and
kick me and then
it'll cut down to my legs and i'll jump
over
your kick and then it cuts back up to us
fighting and we did that and
it was amazing i was so blown away
and yeah just went from there i found
video copilot and the rest is history
so that's kind of that's that's how my
interest was really peaked
in um visual effects editing
production and that kind of stuff
um yeah you know and then and then we
since i love building stuff going back
to the legos
right um
my friend tyler called me and he was
like yo
let's build a tank and i was like yo
okay and it took us a year and we built
a cardboard tank
and um you know cardboard warfare came
out about a year after that
because we just we loved building things
so much we built all the weapons we
built the tanks
and then we filmed carbon warfare so uh
benny i see you
i see you benny thank you for the super
chat much appreciated
he says thanks for teaching me how to
hand paint muzzle flashes and shells
on my og after effects tuts
uh tutorial that was my first experience
with after effects keep doing your thing
namaste dude heck yeah thank you benny
that's awesome
um yeah i used to put out tutorials like
way way back if you guys
go down into the depths of my channel
you'll find some videos that you may
have seen
a long time ago because honestly i
hadn't posted videos in about six years
before i started doing these live
streams and tutorials were a part of the
of the stuff that i put out
um so yeah i did a whole bunch of
tutorials way back
old school stuff and it was funny i was
watching some of my old tutorials
and i i i heard something that i didn't
know
but it came for me it was like the
weirdest thing i was like wait i could
do that i didn't know i could do that
um all right yo you guys have so many
good questions
um let me just start from the bottom
here um what about game dev or modeling
in gaming
i don't know what about it i don't know
anything about it to to be honest with
you
onorag i don't know much um anaz
what is the best free render engine for
cinema 4d
a free render engine for c4d
to be honest with you i don't know i
mean octane isn't free
i don't know if they have cycles for
cinema 4d
i don't know i don't know um
ujjwal gupta please tell about
how to add dirt and scratches by the way
i use blender
sweet okay yeah so you're talking about
surface imperfections
um if you go through some of my live
streams you'll find that i did one on
texturing
you will be able to follow that and get
an idea of how to do it in blender
obviously i'm using c4d but so you guys
know how i put out that
hdri video the custom hdri video well
i'm going to be putting out a surface
imperfection video
right so we're going to actually make
our own surface imperfections from
scratch we're going to have ink we're
going to have paper
we're going to have glass we're going to
be taking photos of it it's going to be
all dirty we're going to scratch it
we're going to get some good fingerprint
um surface imperfections some glass
scratched imperfections maybe some dirt
maps and stuff and we're going
to process them in photoshop and bring
them into our 3d program
and dirty some stuff up so i'm going to
go i'm going to break everything down
for you guys just like i did with the
hdri tutorial i'm going to do that with
surface imperfections so look out for
that that's coming along
um all right scrolling i'm scrolling up
um
let's see let's see
does one need a degree for becoming a
vfx artist
anish um bapat is asking
does one need a degree for becoming a
vfx artist
well i'd consider myself a vfx artist
and i do not have a degree
so i would say no however
like if you're trying to get hired at a
really big vfx house like digital domain
or ilm or you know any of or
red chiles vfx in india you know
honestly like i can't speak to their
individual policies
but from me personally this is just my
belief
is that your work should just be
based off of your work if you can do
solid work if you can produce
really really awesome results then i'm
going to be looking at you
and i'm going to be like okay this guy's
a legit and then
it goes a step further if you actually
you know i reach out and it's like hey i
need to meet this person
and it turns out they're just a horrible
person i'm not going to want to work
with that person because they're
horrible
i want to work with them if they're nice
and humble and passionate and excited
about
the work they're doing um
you know like at the end of the day i
think it comes down to the work that you
put out
um some some places might
require degrees um some places
may not require degrees to be honest i
don't know it depends on the individual
place
but at the end of the day i think it
comes down to the work that you put out
so keep
working on it keep practicing and keep
getting better at the work that you guys
are doing
um keep learning keep learning and keep
growing
keep coming back to this channel we'll
learn and grow together it'll be great
um what's up gilbert my cat is chilling
right here
hey bud let's answer some of these
questions yeah
all right
i'm gonna scroll all the way down and
make sure i didn't miss anything
a lot of tech questions here
hmm have i tried houdini no i have not
tried houdini
i'm learning unreal engine right now
that's where i'm spending all my points
um anaz is asking what the hell
is this whole pbr maps in c4d there is
no clear video on youtube so include it
in one of your live streams pbr
physically based
render i think is what it stands for as
far as i
gather um pbr
materials or shaders are basically um
[Music]
like shaders or okay
a shader is a compilation of textures
um basically and a pbr
shader as far as i know
isn't made up of images
that you download and pipe in to
different
little dealies um basically it's made
from noise maps
so it's completely adjustable
and completely editable as far as i
gather that's what pbr is
like you're going to be able to take the
scratch level down because it's based
off of the
noise and it's all built into the
program
pbr shaders and materials can be
set up in any program that you're using
just not c4d
it could be done in blender it could be
done in unreal engine it can be done
in maya any of that good stuff
james asked did i go to art school i
kind of did i mean
like i said i always took
drawing and art as an elective all the
way through middle school so that's what
two years
seventh and eighth grade here in the
united states and then for high school
ninth grade through twelfth grade um i
took art every single year
so i'm constantly drawing um painting
less so it was more just like pencil or
pen
drawing and whatnot and then from that
point
georgia is actually really cool i was in
atlanta at the time
when i graduated high school from
creekview high school in 2009
and they have this thing called the hope
scholarship where they take
lottery money and they give it to
students who have a grade point average
of 3.0 or above
which is pretty easy to get if you apply
yourself and you
and you you know really just focus and
get that 3.0
it maxes out out at 4.0 right so i got a
3.0
and i went to chattahoochee tech for a
digital media arts degree which is kind
of like
after effects photoshop um
i can't remember if there was cinema 4d
in there there may have been
i can't remember um we did a lot of
drawing
illustrator and
my teacher mr mason was so cool
that he let me just work on my youtube
videos
in after effects class he was like yo i
see the work you're putting out it's
really good
you have your whole youtube channel um
you know how to use after effects you
know you followed all these video
copilot tutorials
do your thing like do your thing man and
that was so cool and
i'm just gonna get right into it so at
that time i had made cardboard warfare
and i had been talking with freddie
right
freddy wong who you guys know ran rocket
jump
and freddie was like dude you should
move out to la
and live in like this little studio
setup i have that's on uh
i mean hunter street basically down in
in downtown
and i was like i would love to
but i don't think i can because i'm like
in college right now and
i would have to drop out and i don't
think my dad's gonna let me drop out but
i'll ask
so i asked my dad hey could i drop out
and
go live with freddie and make videos
and he was like no no way um you got to
get your degree
like i don't care what you do i don't
care what you pursue
after um you get your degree you just
need that degree and i was like oh come
on dad
i had this opportunity and he's like
nope you need the degree so i went to my
i went to mr mason my after effects
teacher and i told him hey
i have this opportunity like my dad's
not letting me go he wants me to get the
degree
but you know i'm being called to come
out to la and do work with with freddie
and he was like drop out just drop out
and go
because you can always come back and
finish
this tech school now keep in mind guys
don't drop out i'm not saying drop out
all right i i was going to chattahoochee
tech i was going to this technical
school for free because of that hope
scholarship if you paid a whole bunch of
money
and you're going to you know some
awesome film school
stay in all right stay in do it i mean
do what's right for you all right i'm
just telling you my situation so
um mr mason said drop out you have the
opportunity like the reason we're going
to school is to get the opportunity
to go out to la you already have the
opportunity to go out to la before
you got your degree so go and i told
that to my dad and my dad said
okay all right i'll let you go
so i packed my car full of all my stuff
all my props all my gear and i was
literally like dragging my car was like
and i drove all the way across country
um i did it in two 18-hour stretches for
36 hours total and i got to la
and met up with freddie and wrapped up
carbon warfare 2 was already filmed at
the time and i
was finishing out finishing the short
out it took me like five months to
finish it
so that was that that was that time um
all right back to your guys's questions
i see some super chats in here so i'm
gonna get these
um christian what's up
christian's always stopping by he says
hey
what's your favorite kombucha dude
you're always dropping me kombucha money
i love it
my favorite kombucha is the gt's
uh ginger kombucha that is my favorite
one
i love how it's spicy and it feels good
like i feel like i'm getting healthier
when i drink it um
and sabir um he says do you accept
interns at corridor
we do but not really to be honest not
really it's more like friends that we
know
um we are you know we basically
put out videos saying hey we're hiring a
corridor
and those are like the only times that
we're reaching out to
everybody um and it's a very
intense process where it's like
thousands of people enter
and it gets whittled down to one or two
people um
so those are like the public hiring
deals we're never
just secretly hiring um
and if we are secretly hiring it's gonna
be a friend of a friend kind of a
situation
so that's kind of what it what it's like
um pravan i see you
hi clint what's your thought about ian
hubert
um ian hubert is basically the best dude
ever
i love him so much i've had the pleasure
of going
up and visiting him multiple times he's
come down here and visited me
multiple times and like he is just the
freaking best
he's such a nice guy he's very wacky
he's very out there
um and he's so freaking talented at what
he
what he does it makes me it makes me
like hurt inside he is so good
um but if you guys don't know who ian
hubert is like
shoot um yeah he's the man
i'm sure you've seen him i'm sure you
guys know ian hubert
uh robot soup that's his website
and it's still down his website is still
down
um ian hubert he has a uh
a patreon at this point but he's on
vimeo
he's on youtube look at his old school
ian hubert
he uses blender that's the craziest
thing and he gets like the nicest looks
at a blender man
this is all cg right here
he's so good oh look at that style
like he has such a great eye i think ian
hubert is like
i can't wait to see a movie he does he's
doing his dynamo series
but oh my goodness yeah the dude is
amazing
i realized my freaking big ol head was
blocking that whole thing
this is why i need to update these
streams guys i need someone to like
help me out with these streams get
someone on the tech side
helping me with this stuff
but that's my goal for next year is to
really like amp these streams up and
make them nicer and more professional
because it's just me it's just me like
doing what i can with the small time
that i have on the weekend
um because you guys know i work at
corridor digital full-time
um but yeah this is ian's work here it's
just absolutely incredible
so nice all right back to full screen
boom all right i'm in
back to the questions where are we at
all right sabir thanks for the super
chat
appreciate you guys um
sanjeeth i appreciate you as well man
thanks for inspiring us
all um this time we love you i love you
man thank you so much
we got a lot of people from all around
the world this is great
oh shoot prove prithvi
thank you sir thank you sir heck yeah it
looks like we got a lot of people from
india
joining the chat this is awesome
definitely a place i want to go to
at some point okay guys
i'm going to answer some of the
questions that i got on the discord all
right
i'm gonna answer one of these questions
and i'll come back to the live chat so
let's see what sparked your passion for
vfx we talked about that one
um johnny bosworth what's up man i don't
know if you're on the live stream here
but you got a question you asked it on
discord he said do you find it hard to
strike a balance
between all your hobbies and passions
my god yes i do all right i'm gonna i'm
actually gonna combine that with another
question
asked by
let's see how do you stay creative in
between work
i'm a student in uni and even if i want
to dig into the nitty-gritty of doing
the vfx work
i feel like i don't have the time nor
the motivation to actually make
something that's from little abraham
and i'm going to combine that also with
um blaster jacks
how do you handle burnout sometimes i
get tired of creating stuff doing it
over and over again
plus lots of learning lots of software
lots of resources out there to make me
so anxious sometimes
i lose sleep thinking about a few scenes
i even dream about viewports and
simulations
i've been there all right i've been
there um it gets real bad
covet has literally taken a toll on my
mouth mental health so would like to
know your point of view on this
all right great so we're gonna talk
about balancing work
and hobbies and passions and the burnout
situation all right okay
let's get into it this is awesome okay
so
um let me get the chat back and
i'll dive in
all right here we go
so for me personally this is gonna be me
speaking about me personally
um i'm not gonna give any advice that uh
that i haven't really been through okay
or if if i do i'll let you know that i
hadn't been through it
okay so i have a ton of hobbies
i have so many things that i want to do
um
like i love drumming is it's my favorite
it's currently
packed up in storage up there i don't
like that that sucks
i love drawing like i have a whole
art book of all my drawings right up
here um
maybe i'll bust it out later that's
certainly a hobby that i want to get
good at
i'm taking japanese lessons right now
and that's another thing that i want to
get good at i want to be able to
go to japan and be able to speak the
language it's important to me
so that's another focus what else what
are their hobbies like i love
photography so much
i love directing i l
i love writing
writing is hard very difficult um i know
i need
to love writing um i
love uh acting and stuff
for friends it's the best what else i
love
um
[Music]
what's up gilbert hey bud
all right rumba you're getting kicked
bud
you're gonna get booted here
um what else what else
i love going outdoors
traveling like there's just a whole lot
of things that i enjoy right
so how do i balance that with work
basically um you have to
take all the things that you love doing
and you need to put them in order
of the most important down to the least
important
and for me the most important thing
right now
or like the top three or four or five
most important things right now
is getting better as a writer getting
better
as a director learning unreal engine
staying physically fit um
and i guess japanese lessons
um all of that stuff is on the side
that's all on the side because i have
corridor that's my main job that's my
full-time job
so i have to do my best work at corridor
while also getting really good at those
other things i don't have time to learn
unreal engine
at corridor i can't be paid to sit there
and learn unreal engine
like it's gonna take hours and hours i i
can start to
like integrate things i've learned into
my real
full-time job but not until i've learned
it and learning it
has to be down the side i cannot get
paid to stay physically fit at corridor
i cannot get paid um to
learn how to write a corridor you get
hired to do the job that you're good at
not you don't get hired to do the job
that you're not good at that you need to
get better at
you're going to get better at stuff like
for me at corridor um
i've gotten really good at vfx at
corridor my vfx has freaking like
really it's it's capping it's i'm the
best i've ever been at vfx since i've
been at corridor
um the writing angle the kind of writing
that i want to do
um like fully fledged out stories and
characters and stuff
not so much i don't get to tweak that
muscle i don't get i don't get to
to work that muscle a whole lot
so i need to do that on the side i need
to spend time and work that muscle on
the side in my free time
so you only have so much time you
basically all right
quasim you're gone done out
yes you spam it and and it's done
it's done this is why
i need a moderator um
okay back to it
um so basically
i have all these hobbies and hopefully
if you put them in order of
uh most important to least important so
now you know where to focus
all right so you have these like handful
of things that you want to get better at
how do you get better at them and how do
you train them uh every day
all right and i still hadn't forgotten
about burnout i'll get i'll get you on
on burnout
so what i do to ensure that i get better
at the
important things that i need to get good
at every single day
is practice them every single day and i
recently read a book
um my library
is like right over here i'll show you
guys
so let me go in and you know what i'm
gonna get an elgato here so i can like
really
do this right but up here i have my art
books
um this is everything that like
like photography books and stuff or
concept art you can see like the art of
titanfall deus ex
right in the middle there that colorful
thick one is
the um kowloon walled city in hong kong
it's a photo book of all that so it's
just like a bunch of different
places around the world to give me
certain vibes and get inspired with
the one on the far left or the far right
i guess for you guys
this one here that's all my film
photography
printed out so down here is my murakami
collection that's all the haruki
murakami novels
and then i got like my old playstation 1
games on the left and all my amiibos
and i got my music back there so then
down here
are all of my uh like film books and
stuff
you know all the stuff that i've learned
sorry guys this is tough
we're gonna get better at this all my
film books
um and acting books and writing books
and visual
you know all the stuff and steven
pressfield books and then down here we
got cookbooks
and then way down there is just like
fiction
um other fiction but i saved the top for
murakami that's the special section
if you guys don't know who haruki
murakami is then
well look him up he's my favorite
all right what was i saying
we were talking about how to get good at
stuff oh yeah yeah this book this book
the 5 a.m club this is incredible uh hey
what's up eli
friggin eli's up in here eli works over
at black rifle coffee we've been good
friends for a long long time we met at
pax randomly we bumped into each other
four times in a row in one day
um and the rest is history eli is such a
good friend of mine
what's up son but yeah okay this book
right here 5am club
this is how i'm able well i learned a
lot from this okay
basically this teaches you how to make
the most
of your your mornings and ultimately how
to make the most of your life
to be honest um because it talks about
how to structure your morning in a way
um that okay so you have your heart set
your mindset your health set and your
skill set these are four areas of your
life
that the book talks about um
you know training and getting better so
that every single day you're getting
better at those things
so you wake up you work out for 20
minutes the next 20 minutes
is spent um either journaling about
what you're going to do this day how
you're going to max out this day
it could be spent meditating it could be
spent stretching the third 20 minutes is
spent learning
so in my case i've just been watching
unreal tutorials for those
you know last 20 minutes of that hour at
5am
i'm doing it at 6am
and that means that if i'm if i'm doing
20 minutes of unreal tutorials
every single day after a year dude it's
going to be crazy
i'm going to know so much about unreal
the whole point is consistency you have
to be consistent
in your pursuits we have a lot of
passions
and you want to be able to zoom in
on those and take out little chunks and
practice it in little chunks and you
have to be patient you have to be so
patient
and i feel like patience is going to be
one of those things that is quickly
going to disappear
as we move on into the future because we
have everything now
we get everything as soon as possible
and there's no patience anymore
and if i can train myself to be as
patient as possible
and as disciplined as possible and to
consistently
learn as much as possible consistently
right
because that's what it's going to be
that's how you're going to get good is
consistent learning
if you drop off and you quit then you're
not going to learn anymore
but if you're spending 20 minutes a day
learning something new
in my case it's unreal engine or film
photography we just developed our own
film
then you're going to max out your life
if you can do that every single day for
the rest of your life you're going to be
the best version of you that you could
ever be
and it's going to take a lot of hard
work but you know
it's what has to be done and holy crap
it's caves
what the heck dude man if you guys don't
know
caves put out a freaking awesome video
game actually
um caves what i think caves rd is his
instagram
but he is an unreal master he put out a
video game where you like have a camera
and you walk around
uh mount inari or not is it mount inari
it's the shrine in uh
kyoto and you take photos and he did one
of like uh
of uh iceland as well
so sick um all right he says yo clint
what about un what about unreal made you
decide to dive in what kind of stuff do
you
want to be able to make let me know if
you need any help dude you are the best
so the thing that got me asked about
unreal
obviously the the rebirth trailer the
qixel rebirth
trailer um and
recently the unreal 5 demo blew my mind
and then there was this other short
called memories of australia
all of it is just insane it's absolutely
incredible
and it's all real time and it makes me
want it's like
why render something why spend the time
rendering if you can get
this if you can get this max quality in
real time
i want that i definitely want that and
i'm always trying to learn as much as
possible i see it as like
unreal is an incredibly powerful tool
that if i don't know as a vfx artist i'm
gonna be in trouble
i would rather be on top of my game the
more i know
the more valuable i am the better off i
am um
and the whole reason i was interested in
3d graphics
in general is was was basically
i thought that if i
can think of something i can create it
and the only thing stopping me from from
transferring it
from my head to a complete image
is the technical know-how and the time
to do it
um that's it
so why not learn how to how to do it
if you can think it you can put it out
the whole point is to make movies i want
to make movies i want to tell awesome
impactful stories
with amazing characters that blow your
mind soothe the soul
you know make you cry make you laugh
that's what i want to do
and by learning unreal engine i can
create some awesome
scenes and some awesome atmospheres and
and landscapes
that no one else could create because
they don't know unreal or
it's going to give me a leg up as a
director so that that's totally why
um everything i learn
when it comes to being creative um
it all it all kind of is so that i can
create
better movies that's why
um caves super awesome of you to stop by
man
this is awesome round over i missed the
super chat
i'm scrolling up
thanks brother um hi clint
omron here from india what's up omran uh
imran sorry should i start vfx channel
on youtube
what's the scenario in 2020 is it worth
dude
do what's passionate for you all right
round
or imran um do what's passionate for you
man
like i
am like i have a lot of goals you know i
want to make a youtube channel um i have
my youtube channel here
you know it kind of died over the last
six years and i wanted to resurrect it
um because i'm passionate about all this
stuff i'm super passionate about
learning
educating creating super cool things but
yeah dude
imran like why would you not create a
youtube channel for vfx
dude post your stuff even if it's just a
place for you to post your work
just for you to track it so that later
maybe when your kid when you have kids
you can show your kids hey this is all
my work this is like the timeline of all
my work and how i got better better
you're you're tracking your progress
with the youtube channel so absolutely
dude
and for it to be successful
or semi-successful that's going to take
a long time i promise you that will take
a long time
and you are going to need the discipline
and the patience
to nurture that right but if it's a
passion for you
then you're going to do it anyway right
so do it so just do it
there's nothing stopping you from
starting youtube channel and posting
the stuff that makes you passionate onto
that channel all right
and if people like it they're gonna like
it they're gonna ask for more they're
gonna comment all that good stuff
and you know you're going to continue
doing it and in my case i see that you
guys love these live streams so i'm
trying to figure out the best way to
make these better for you guys
and the better they are the more people
will come
the more i do it the more consistently i
do it the more people come today is my
girlfriend's birthday
luckily she's at a dentist appointment
right now
but i was like i gotta get a video out
like i know it's your birthday
but i gotta get a video out and again
she she's off to
uh to a dennis appointment so i do have
the time right now
um i would have pre-recorded something
and posted it for you guys but it's you
got to be consistent if you want it to
be
a thing you know what i mean all right
what else we got
i got another super chat here um ollie
yo what's up dude okay he says hi clint
i think you should do a collaboration
with hat films because there's a guy
called smith who's basically the british
version of nico
okay i'll look into it hat films
i'm writing it down i'll write it down
okay
hat films and there's a dude named
smith okay
got it that might be backwards for you
but i got it right
thank you sir thank you ali thank you
for the super chat
um louisa louisa okay deep question if
it's all right
i'm down for deep deep questions my guy
let's go all the way
have you ever had issues with body image
do you have
any advice for people who struggle with
body dysmorphia or
image of one's self
uh cute hat thank you so much this is
actually my girlfriend's hat
um okay
body image i okay let's see
probably not to the extent that
that you're asking probably not to the
extent that you're asking
um i can only speak to what i
what i know for myself personally i love
working out
well i don't know about love working out
i need to work out if i don't work out
then
um i'm not going to be my best
emotionally i'm not going to be the best
um i'm very cranky i i'm short
with people especially my i can be short
with my girlfriend
if i don't work out um
and part of the reason why i work out is
to look
good you know you know you got your
shoulders you got
you got your biceps you got your triceps
you know
um i don't got a six pack
i got like a flabby kind of a four pack
yes i would love to be super chiseled
and like freaking jacked out
and lean like bruce lee like the bruce
lee is like the vibe you know
um and i have gotten to be honest i have
gotten upset
at times and i've looked at myself like
what the heck is this what the heck is
this
what's all this freaking side fat why
why do i have this freaking
side fat hanging off why do i have this
belly right here
um so
i could be very hard on myself and very
judgmental of myself
um when i see those things and at times
i can be judgmental of other people too
like it's it's not healthy
it's certainly not healthy i have no
reason
to judge anybody else for
the way they look or their body right
but
because i'm so hard on myself and i hold
myself to such a high level
in turn it's like i want to hold
everyone to this high level
in my head you know i'm not going around
telling people do this do that
but those thoughts slip into my head
certainly
and i can get upset at myself for
not being strong enough not being lean
enough not eating healthy enough
i always try and eat healthy enough but
this morning i had a donut
what the heck i don't need a donut i
really don't need a donut i need to be
eating as healthy as possible um
so that's about the extent like of
my issue when it comes to um
body image body dysmorphia that kind of
stuff
i know that a lot of people struggle
with it to a much worse extent
i personally cannot speak to that level
because i hadn't experienced it but
that's about it for me you know
i i i just want to be as healthy as
possible i want to look as good as
possible
and can kind of beat myself up for not
being at that level
but i just know that if i
if i put the work in and i train myself
enough
and if i take care of myself i don't
need to worry about anyone else
i just need to worry about about me um
so i guess what i'm saying is work hard
um and
i guess yeah for me i just need to keep
working out i need to keep working out
um but it might be a little bit
different than
the body dysmorphia you're talking about
um
but be healthy yeah be healthy treat
yourself
be kind to yourself and
yeah don't go too hard on yourself i
think i could use that advice as well
all right moving on i appreciate the
deep questions i am all about the deep
questions
i will answer any deep question let's
see what else we got
um let's make movies you got a super
chat thanks brother all right
would you ever consider going into
blender and using that for vfx and have
you seen what ian hubert on youtube
has been doing yeah so i just talked
about ian hubert
the dude is incredible freaking love
that guy so much
we're actually pretty good friends um i
am
constantly inspired by him like
i have a dream team in my head and he's
on that dream team all right like
he's on the freaking team uh and have i
considered going into blender for vfx
nope
i have not this is a big question you
guys asked us all the time
clint why don't you use blender all
right i'll tell you why i don't use
blender
reason number one um
i started with cinema 4d
release 10. why i started with cinema 4d
i don't even remember i don't even know
blender was an option at that point
there was 3ds max and
and cinema 4d those are my options about
12 years ago um so i started with c4d i
went with c4d for like three years i'm
putting my time into c4d
that'd be like me learning unreal engine
giving up and going to unity
like why i've put this time into unreal
i'm going to continue my unreal engine
training um but
i legit did that i legit got fed up with
c4d
after year two or three and was like
there's no good tutorials for this
i'm making the tutorials for this i i
shouldn't be making the tutorials for
c4d
i want the good tutorials i want to
watch and follow the tutorials
looking back though in hindsight i
should have stuck with c4d because
i could have made something like
grayscale gorilla you know
there's a hole there people want good
tutorials i should have kept going and
made the good tutorials
you know that's kind of how i feel with
unreal right now
anyway i switched to 3ds max because
two reasons one there was a ton of
really good 3ds max
tutorials that i could follow and learn
a lot quicker i learned faster i was
impatient i wanted to learn as fast as
possible
number two the people around me were
using 3ds max
freddy and brandon were using 3ds max
sam and nico were using 3ds max
so naturally if i had a question for
them it'd be 3ds max that's what they
know so i'm like okay i'll switch to 3ds
so the main reason that i'm using we
went back to c4d
okay i'm back to c4d and that's because
maxon reached out to corridor like yo we
love you guys we want to hook you guys
up
they hooked us up with c4d and i'm like
yes i love i loved c4d in the past it
was the best
it reinvigorated my my flame my zest for
3d
right and the reason why is because
everyone around me was using cinema 4d
i'm basically using the program that
everyone around me is using that way we
can all
figure it out together if i was off on
my own just doing whatever
and i was on a budget dude blender all
day
no problem but because like
mac the guys at maxson are so nice like
they hook it up for sure
they're really the best they have a
really nice community and family
i'm on c4d like i'm on i'm on the train
man it's the best i love it
it works for me i've been putting all my
points into it for a long time
there'd be no reason for me to stop that
and move to something else like
i'm doing that but with unreal engine
for a couple other reasons right
unreal engine it's not it's not 3ds max
or blender or maya
you know all of these things are kind of
like c4d equivalents
it's serving other purposes so that's
why i'm trying to learn a new program
it's like
i only have so much time how do i use my
time the wisest
learn something that will actually serve
a purpose for my future
blender it would just take me
however long to learn to just do what i
can do in cinema 4d you know
so no reason for me to switch
um thanks for the question though that's
a good question i know a lot of you guys
had similar questions
all right i'm scrolling down i'm hitting
these super chats here um
we got um
izzy have i ever played far cry 5
whenever i see you with the beard and
glasses oh my god
yeah i've heard this um
yeah i look like the bad guy from far
cry 5. i have not played far cry 5.
um my buddy adrian who actually worked
at corridor for a while
he's the first person to tell me like yo
you look like this dude from from this
video game
and that's like the funniest thing ever
i looked at the pictures and it straight
up does
like
it's with the scarf when i put the scarf
on
and i take the hat off let me see
kind of yeah like i kind of look like
like them if i like get the hair clip in
there
which i hadn't been wearing hair clips
until quarantine started but
yeah basically this is the vibe right
here this is it my mustache is
freaking along i gotta trim that holy
crap
i got some rogue mustache hairs going um
but yeah basically i'm the guy from far
cry 5 at this point so
um mr mr ram one more
one more freaking by nod and you are
gone
oh he's gone gone
this is the dumbest meme this is the
freaking stupidest thing i don't even
i'm not going to talk about it
you getting kicked kicked son all right
back to it
um
all right we're all caught up on the
super chats
so let me answer
burnout we talked about burnout but i
didn't i didn't get to it all right
burnout um very briefly
uh yeah i i was super burnt out before i
went on vacation
uh a couple weeks ago because all i did
from wake
from from sun up to sundown was vfx just
working in vfx
oh my god another thing that this 5 a.m
club book
talks about right here freaking love
this if you guys
are like disciplined or want to be as
disciplined as possible
um and ready to freaking elevate your
life
then definitely check out this book 5am
club a good friend of mine
um oh wes actually his friend
was good right so was good he has a good
friend show me this book we all got on
it it's the best
it talks about doing less work taking
more vacations
taking more breaks doing less work
it actually makes the work you do more
potent
more detailed more focused um
you're gonna get better results if you
can just relax
for a little bit all right so with
burnout
the kind of the kind of uh like
structure that this book talks about
basically alleviates that because it's
got you waking up super early in the
morning the first
hour in your morning is for you all
right you don't touch your phone
until like late way later in the day and
when you're done with your day
you don't touch your phone you get off
of your phone when you're done with work
you're done you put your phone away you
spend time with your family you spend
time with your kids you spend time
um if it's just you chilling if it's if
it's you living with your parents
you spend time with your family spend
time with your friends just get off your
phone
you know get off social media um and and
go and relax
go and chill i i think i heard on um
like a joe rogan podcast
they were saying how um
the phones and social media are training
us
to um
basically training us to be distracted
um we don't want that we don't want that
at all
so yeah take your breaks take your
vacations
um if you think about it how much time
we put in working
every single year to take two weeks off
three weeks off is ridiculous you need
to be taking like
months off i feel like take a fifth of
your year
off that'd be nice if we could do that
certainly
um don't worry guys i am i'm taking care
of the chat
i understand um
okay so that's burnout right now we're
caught up we are caught up
so let's uh
let's talk about some of these at
punishers here
let's see oh okay alan
asks hey is there a reason you're not
active on your twitter account
yeah exactly for that reason because
it's just another thing to check i don't
need i don't need the
i don't need all this social media to
check like i'm good with instagram
and discord i'm basically checking i'm
checking the discord server that we got
and i'm checking instagram every day
that that's that's what i check
i don't do facebook anymore i don't
do twitter anymore um
tik tok hadn't even thought about it
there's just too much stuff for me
there's too much for me to work on
to have to divert my focus and break up
my focus i don't need to be checking
twitter
i'm good with instagram i'm a
photographer it's a visual thing you
know
so it just works better for me colin
what's up dude
thanks for the super chat colin he says
i'm going to
uga film school um soon
inspired by you guys at rocket jumping
corridor thanks
so much for introducing me to my passion
also do you miss rj at all
heck yeah i miss rj man i freaking
freaking love freddy and um all those
guys are very very talented like
if if uh if corridor
is like the vfx powerhouse
and i'm learning about vfx my vfx skills
are going to the max at corridor
rocket jump was where i took my writing
to the max
and oh man i need to get better as a
writer
so bad and i learned so much from matt
and will um at rocket jump man those
guys are like
they were blowing my minds every single
day we were sitting down and we were
writing a feature together
and it never came about but we were
there for like a month and a half
like right at the end right when rocket
jump um
like when everyone kind of went their
separate ways and uh
for about a month and a half maybe two
months i don't maybe have been three
months four months i can't remember
we were just in there every single day
working this movie out and like
you had your cards up on the wall your
character sheets broken down
it was so good it was so so good
and to actually to hop
into a question that one of you guys
asked on the discord
um let me find it okay
firefighter seafood asked have you ever
read any books on storytelling
if so what can you recommend um
this is a perfect segue yes i have read
books on storytelling
that matt and will told me about and
it's right here
it's by robert mckee it's called story
i take my uh my little like
wrapping my book wrapping stuff off what
is it called a jacket
a sheath a book sheath i don't know um
it's called story by robert mckee
this is like the bible of storytelling
right here
it's guys do yourself a favor if you
want to get better as a writer
get this book story please get this book
and when you're done with this book
and you learn about everything you can
about story
and this this takes it back this book
takes it back like story is ingrained in
all of us
there's there's a um what is it there
there there is a like a structure story
structure for a reason
um but if you follow it exactly like
i think save the cat talks about the
story structure if you follow it and do
the cookie cutter thing it's going to be
cliche you need to know
how to get out of that cliche you need
to know how to make your story special
and make it feel
make it feel good and it's not always
about structure
but you need to know that there is
structure and why it works so this is a
deep understanding on story pick this up
if you guys want to learn about story
and when you're done with that you're
going to want to check
out um dialogue by the same guy
robert mckee dialogue and he gets into
like why dialogue sucks
and how to make it good um and how to
make it have like subtext
and write writing dialogue for your
characters
these these books oh yes these books
are like this is it right here okay this
is all you need to worry about
um so yeah i missed my time at rj
we had a lot of good time it was like it
was like corridor just
you know with other people um
making different shorts you know it's
like they're similar but they're
different
i miss him a lot i love freddie he's
such a good guy very
very kind and humble guy and he's
learned a lot since he started
um
sweet we're caught up again look at look
at that
who do i mean in smash ness ness is my
main my boy right here
um but then i'm i'm pretty good with
snake i can mess around with snake a
little bit
uh yeah these these are my guys are here
and i'm trying to get good with pikachu
pikachu is is definitely quick
it doesn't have a lot of uh like smash
power but hey
all good i really appreciate you guys
hanging in here
this is awesome this is really fun
let's keep going let's uh let's keep
asking some more cool questions
and then i'm going to announce the uh
the weekly challenge winners
at the end we'll probably cut out in the
next 30 or so again it is my
girlfriend's birthday today so i don't
want to be streaming
all day that's why i'm doing a q a let's
keep it a little shorter today but um
i'm only looking at the app punishers
right now in the chat if you have a
question
um let's see
let's see
yeah okay uh anaz working on c4d is
tiresome and exhausting do you have any
tips to avoid procrastination
and ideal stretches that you follow
ideal stretches
like yoga stretches okay anyway
procrastination i'll put it in terms of
writing for me
i could sit behind this computer and do
vfx all day
like it you don't have to tell me to do
any i will be at this computer and i
will do some vfx and make some cool
stuff
like it it's a problem it can be a
problem
um but for me when it comes to
procrastination
let's talk about writing writing is
freaking so hard
it's very difficult for me to sit down
and write
but last year i forced myself
to spend an hour every single morning
writing the full hour just one hour
um and i did that for about four months
consistently
on the weekdays on the weekdays i took
the week weekends off
and i came up with like four or five
shorts
the work came came from the discipline
um of doing it every single every single
day
you have to have a reason why you're
pursuing something why you're
you're forcing yourself to do something
like if i just went outside and like
tried to force myself to get good at
pottery every day for an hour i would
give up so fast because there's no
reason for me to do it
like what's the reason for you to get
good at c4d for me with writing
it's so that like literally the greatest
work the greatest movies out there
the greatest books the greatest shows
it's about the story
everything else doesn't matter it's all
about the story all this like
v effects and like fancy editing
that's all extra but at the end of the
day it comes down to story if you can't
tell a good story
then like why am i trying to be a
director you know what am i doing
so for me that's so important that's
like if you if you can't do this then
you're not gonna you're not gonna make
it sorry so for me it's like
live or die get good good get really
good at writing and storytelling
or else so that's my reasoning why are
you trying to get good at cinema 4d
is it because you need to survive and
and and get paid for something you love
doing that's a great reason that's a
really good reason
so keep it up just know that the work
you're putting in it might be hard like
no one likes working out
it sucks but when you're done working
out
you feel so good and just like with c4d
when you're putting in the work every
day consistently
and it's like ah this sucks work towards
an end goal put something out
finish something finish something that
is so important because you can look at
that finished thing and be like
i made that i finished that like i want
to do that again that was really cool
and you're going to continue to drive
yourself
it'll be like a circle a cycle a couple
books
that talk about this stuff that i am
absolutely in love with we got
um we got turning pro by stephen
pressfield
this book scared me it was like yo
you want to be a writer right well
what are you doing right now are you
writing because writers
professional writers they write whether
they want to or not
they are in a constant state of writer's
block and whether
they're stuck for two days or two months
they're going to write every single day
whether they're stuck or not
and that was like whoa and also it was
like you know what
you have a shadow career stopping you
from doing what you really need to be
doing
and i was like holy crap so you're
saying that like
by taking this job or that job i'm like
putting myself in like a safe area so i
don't have to go out of my comfort zone
to
do what i really know i need to do and
it gets into all that like
whew this book is good and then he also
stephen pressfield he has a bunch of
books on writing and
and uh discipline do the work is
probably his most famous one
steven pressfield do the work he talks
about
uh when you're sitting down to write and
you
want to check instagram that's called
resistance
it's stopping you from writing you're
writing and then you want to get eat a
snack
but you're not really hungry that's
called resistance stopping you from
writing
he breaks down resistance and talks
about it as like the enemy and you want
to
crush resistance at all by all means
possible
so that's a really really good book for
being disciplined about a certain task
also another book i don't have it with
me but it's called
mastery there's two books called mastery
just make sure you get the right one all
right it's called mastery
and it's about consistently doing a task
that's the best way to get good at
something and the reason that's hard
is because let's say you just start out
um you get really good at golfing you
get like you buy all the stuff
you buy the clubs you get the bags you
know you get your membership all that
you go
all in and you get good at golfing like
you really get good right
but the graph will eventually start to
cap
out just like i'm looking at this stream
graph right now
it started out like yeah and then it's
capping right we're capped right here
there's like 250 people in here
boom right it levels out and that level
may not move
for a year and for the people that want
that instant fix
they're gonna quit they're gonna go like
yeah this is awesome i'm learning so
much this
feels good and you're gonna hit this
plateau and you're like i don't like
this
i don't like the plateau i want that
plateau again
eh quit start something else get into
another hobby
boom i love the plateau like it feels so
i love that that rise boom it feels good
and then you start plateauing again it's
like ah i want that i want that feeling
again
you drop off you start another hobby
like that's the worst thing you could be
doing
you need to be consistent with your
endeavors
right um so
the idea is that in the beginning you'll
cap
you'll max out boom you'll hit the
plateau within the first
six months three months whatever and
you're gonna plateau for a year maybe
and guess what at the end of that year
if you stick with it it'll go like this
the graph will go whoop
just a little bit just a little bit
and it's going to be super subtle and
you're going to be like you're going to
look back and like oh that feels good
i think i'm getting better and you do
that year after year
after year after year after year after
year and you will eventually become a
master
um isn't that right gilbert isn't that
right if you eat every day you're gonna
get
bigger and bigger
so will will campos at rocket jump
explained it to me like this because i
was so frustrated
i was like dude writing is so hard
this sucks i'm not i don't enjoy this
and he was like well dude when you
played dark souls did you enjoy
losing like the entire game
did you feel like you were getting
better
throughout the entire game and i was
like no
and he's like exactly and when you went
back to the beginning
did you realize how much you've grown
when like when you started the game over
and i was like yeah actually yeah he's
like well riding is the same thing
and i was like what what you just blew
my mind
because you're getting better but
the challenges are getting harder so
you're getting better like this
but the challenges are getting harder at
the same level
and you're like i'm just stuck i'm not
getting better this is the worst because
it's getting hard like it's getting
harder
and you're getting better at the same
time but if you were to go like
if you were to start the game over and
go back to look at your first script or
look at your first render be like oh
this
sucks i've gotten so much better so just
you have to stick with it
just continue and stick with it
beat dark souls okay i still need to
beat dark souls 3.
um i saw a super chat i don't want to
miss you
um rightly pearson sweet okay i
absolutely love you and all the work
uh all your work i'm wondering should i
dedicate my time to learning blender or
unreal as far as
helping with filmmaking okay yeah
awesome
so
good question it just depends on like
for me okay for me i'm in unreal all
right i just know because i'm already in
blender or i'm sorry i'm already in
cinema 4d
i have a good good basis let's go
and learn something new i'm going to
learn unreal now for you
if you're starting out and you don't
have any 3d background i would say jump
into blender
because that's going to give you like
your foundation blender will give you
your foundation
um and you'll be able to go from there
unreal is very
very technical and complicated and oh
there's so much there's so much
it's a video game engine you're making a
video game
and then you're adding sound design to
it like there's so much
you don't want to get overwhelmed
there's it's possible
that you'll get overwhelmed very quickly
and you'll have to know to just stick in
with it stick through
right but i think if you were to learn
blender first if you don't know any of
those programs
start with blender yeah definitely start
with blender come back to unreal later
it'll be there for you
so don't worry about that and check out
blender guru and ian hubert they got
really nice tutorials for you
they will take care of you
tsar not sorry that's the that's the
currency
um brandon what's up dude how you doing
okay what are my thoughts on unreal five
breaking the polygon barrier
how will software like c4d or blender be
able to support billions and billions of
polygons okay
uh what are my thoughts on unreal five
breaking the polygon beer i think it's
groundbreaking i think unreal engine is
the future
truly is the future um which is why i'm
trying to learn it
um how will software like blender or c4d
be able to support
they'll figure it out hey you know like
technology is advancing every single day
all right so
um it's it's all going to catch up right
it's all going to catch up
cinema 4d and blender they have like
they're just
different programs you there are a lot
of things that you can't do in unreal
that you can do in blender and c4d okay
so
they serve different purposes there's
definitely overlap right there's
certainly some overlap but like if this
is blender and this is
uh unreal like your venn diagram might
be somewhere like in there
so it's not like you have to quit a
certain program to go to another
you're just learning new tools right
um all right what else do we got we're
caught up
you know i probably have time for a
couple more questions my girlfriend gets
back from her dentist appointment soon
and i want to be able to spend time with
her it is her birthday
um
okay yeah vfx wizard good question do
you have time do you have a process
for coming up with new ideas when do you
find and think of your best ideas
great question i always carry
around with me
a journal
or a notepad right here so if i have an
idea
i can write it out i also have my phone
i can type it out whatever my thumbs are
freaking huge so i
constantly am having to go back and
spell correct everything and it drives
me nuts
so i'd rather just write it um
definitely it's like a muscle coming
with ideas is like a muscle
so the more you do it the better you'll
get right
so when we're brainstorming at work and
you're bouncing ideas off of a person it
definitely helps to have a
brainstorming partner um
coming up with ideas calling a friend
saying hey i got this idea what do you
think about this and then you bounce it
around for a little bit
and then they'll come up with an idea
that you hadn't thought about and
that'll give you an idea to come up with
another idea you know
so having a brainstorming partner helps
a lot and
not letting any good idea or decent idea
or whatever idea slip by
okay write it down and review it look
look at it later um another reason
why this book is the best the 5 a.m club
it talks about
journaling and reviewing your day you
need to review your day
think about all the things that were
good that were bad how you can change it
and writing down all of your ideas is
definitely crucial i also have a trello
board if you guys
know about trello look into trello i
know there's a couple
other services that do something similar
but i use trello because
i'm able to quickly type out ideas and
pin them to this board
and i can move them around like note
cards if you were writing a a movie or
something you have your note cards and
you pin them up against the wall
so trello is a great way for me to track
my thoughts
and my ideas and i'll just pop onto my
phone
edit the trello done and i can look at i
look at it at trello every morning every
night
and it's a checklist for me so i'm able
to track how much i'm getting done
um so yeah certainly write down all your
ideas find a brainstorming partner find
someone who like has the same kind of
like
comedic humor as you comedic style as
you um and surround yourself with people
that make you better
right and i promise you your ideas will
start capping out also take breaks um
i've come up with dumb stuff in the
shower i've come up with actually i had
a dream this is crazy i had a dream
about cardboard warfare three
like last week and i woke up
and immediately wrote it down because i
did not want to forget it was like it
was a direction to go for cardboard
warfare 3 which i
am doing i'm promising you guys i'm
going to do it and it's going to be
sci-fi
and it's gonna be amazing all right i
don't know when it's gonna happen but it
will happen
um don't let those ideas slip away write
them down
right cherish them
um all right back to it what do we got
looking at the app punishers here what's
your take on quality versus quantity
this is from anaz i have spent so much
time trying to perfect every single
thing in my project should i
make more or uh should i be making more
or should i be taking my time
that's a good one that's a good question
yeah what's the quantity versus quality
um balance i personally am very
detail-oriented
and love making something look really
good
now you have to think about it
critically and ask yourself
to get the look of this five percent
better is it going to take
90 of my time that would be nope just
move on okay
but you do want to finish things you
want to finish things
we actually did a podcast with
andrew price he is the blender guru
it was me and ren we did it on corridor
cast
so definitely go check that out and we
talked about
um that exact question and his idea on
it was
you need to finish things it's why he
doesn't do the everyday thing
uh like the people thing his idea with
that is that if you just do this every
day
you're not gonna you're not gonna get
any better than that you're just giving
yourself a day
give yourself two weeks give yourself a
week or three give yourself a month
really like you're working a different
muscle you know
you need to think outside the box a
little bit and you need to
push harder now there's also the people
who spend
like five years on a video
yo you need to you need to move on you
need to move on to the next thing
i think like spending a month or two on
a project is great
um maybe three months on a project is
amazing
that for me it gives me enough time to
like put my detail work into it
and spend really good time on it and
make it look nice i don't want to
release anything that
is shoddy half quality i need to
make it the best i can make it right um
but if it's gonna take you a freaking
year to do
maybe maybe it takes you a year i don't
know carpet warfare two took me
six months seven months but it was super
worth it i had so much fun along the way
but i was i wasn't i wasn't like
sitting there tweaking pixels i was
doing the work that needed to be done to
finish the project because it was just
me it's just one guy
doing it so that's gonna take a little
bit longer by default you just have to
ask yourself am i being ridiculous here
like
am i being productive am i spending my
time the wisest
another book for you
is called eat that frog i think it's in
my bedroom
it's called eat that frog and it talks
about how to maximize your productivity
um and spend your time on the most
important
things first thing of the day spend all
your time getting the most important
thing done first
and not until you're finished with that
do you move on to the second most
important thing first
and then you finish that as opposed to
just going all around the list i'll do
this i'll do that
no you need to think about what's the
most important thing
put it to the top and start with that
first thing and and knock that out
this 5 a.m club book talks about the
same thing
um okay back to questions
will you do a duo stream with ren ian
hubert or people in the future
mr uh dingle winkle
darren is that you i don't know but
darren's one of our mods
um
so um will i do a duo stream yes
absolutely i will do a duo stream i have
a list of guests that i am dying to do
this with and i think it will probably
be
i have here's the thing i have to figure
out how to technically do it
to do a dual stream i don't know how to
do a co-lab stream
my stream knowledge is kind of low and
it's something that i should prioritize
a little bit higher on my list
and learn a little bit more about
because yeah i want to do dude
here's here's like the dream here's the
dream i want to do streams
with people um i want to do streams with
ren i want to do streams with ian hubert
i want to do streams with andre librov
that would be
dude that would be awesome i want to do
a stream with
ash thorpe um i would love to do a
stream
with uh dude heck yeah friggin octane
jesus
david he'd be down i'd love to do a
stream with ej
yeah there's just so many people that i
wouldn't i want to collaborate with
i just need to figure out how to oh i
want to do a stream with uh
um chris schmidt certainly and i'd love
to do a stream with matthias
like there's a lot of there's a lot of
people i want to stream with
and i think it could be really fun um
but i just need to figure out how to do
it
so that'll certainly happen it'll
certainly happen
what else we got guys what else do we
got
what's my favorite person to work with
at corridor okay yeah
good question each person
has a different like attribute
or a different like um quality that i
love about them
so sam i love coming up with stories
with sam
he's my favorite person to write with at
corridor by
like by far we can really sit down
and break a story down and break a a
short down
without thinking about money or budget
or timeline
like we're able to put that stuff aside
and really think about what's the best
idea
and let's take it to the max he's really
really good with that
um so i love working i love writing with
sam i love doing
vfx with ren he's my favorite person to
do vfx with because ren is so talented
like we bounce off of each other so well
we give each other these notes um
that are just so good they're so crispy
right in that moment it's like hey you
should do this and tweak that and he's
like oh yeah
yeah perfect and there's no ego with any
of us it's just like
let's just make this the best that we
can um and
like we kind of complement each other
i'm more of like the uh
the cg 3d guy and ren is more of like
the after effects compositing guy
and we we team up and collaborate so
well together
um who else like
nick and dean both of those guys on the
corridor crew side of things
i love spending time with them i love
spending time with both of those guys
um because it's really kind of like a
break
for me from from corridor
spending time with nick and dean on crew
i just get to like relax not think about
work
and just have fun and we're able to
like they're they're able i'll give them
any performance they want anything that
they
want i'll i'll amp it up in a certain
way
a lot of like the corridor crew kind of
stuff um
is it's elevated just a little bit
and we'll kind of joke around and
pretend like we're being
straight faced and like yeah you know as
a kid i wanted to
it was my dream to transform into uh
optimus prime like that's just a goofy
little thing that nick came up with
that i that i delivered in a certain way
so me and nick have this really nice
kind of vibe when we're filming crew
stuff and it's the same with dean
dean is such a good dude i love him a
lot
so like those are basically the
collaborators and then nico
nico is really good to and to he takes
like uh
he'll take the final vision or he'll
take like what me and sam
right we'll bust out this thing and
he'll be like
from a business side i think you need to
tweak this this and this
in order for us to get this done and
he'll put these restraints on us that at
first we're like
but then when you think about it it's
like no you're right that made it better
that did make it better so nico has that
touch that
he that zest you know at the end which
really really helps um
it may not be fun to hear in the moment
but
at the end of the day it's the right
call and it's the way to go
um yeah
yeah all right last couple questions
actually real quick
i got i got two more questions these
last two super chats and then i'm gonna
announce the stream winners or the
challenge winners okay and then i gotta
bounce because my girlfriend's birthday
she's probably gonna text she just
called me um
[Music]
but uh okay quinn
asks any other vr projects in the works
at corridor i work with vr for
in just in industrial training and i
know corridor creatively could bring
some really cool ideas to
the entertainment space yes corridor is
releasing a website soon
and um i don't know how much i'm
supposed to say but there's some
exciting stuff coming
one of them one of the things has to
deal with uh
with vr okay so i'll say that much
exciting stuff
and then we got uh double
t92 asks what do you think
would be the best option to get
experience in video game development
i have an associate's degree in video
game design it's been three years i live
in fort lauderdale
crazy fort lauderdale that's where my
uncle is the firefighter captain
my grandpa he's passed now
was a firefighter and he's in the fort
lauderdale uh firefighter like memorial
crazy that's weird okay okay but you're
asking what do you think would be the
best option to get experience in video
game development
um dude i don't i don't develop video
games
but i would just go to the um
go to the websites of all the video game
developers that you love
whether it's guerrilla games or naughty
dog
or stress level zero whatever
valve look at look at their hiring lists
career go to careers jobs and look at
what they're hiring for and see
what you need to get that job
and focus on those areas um the only
reason i say that is because i was
looking at i was looking at a qixel
their
like their job application thing and it
was saying like i was just curious
and it was saying uh if you want to do
like photo scans you need to know this
or if you know if you want to know this
you have to know that so maybe that's a
good direction for you to go
double um
that's about all i have uh francisco
campos holy crap thank you sir awesome
super chat
didn't even have a question he was like
you know what i got you
shoot you guys are awesome thank you so
much for all the questions
um i feel like we should do this once a
quarter
um or or maybe more i don't know
i feel like once a week or i'm sorry
once a month would be
too much but maybe once a quarter going
into the new
um the new season
what can we do like we'll touch base
every season
every quarter i like that
um javier how do you choose the best
partners
slash friends man that's such a personal
thing
i i try to surround myself with the best
people possible i don't want to spend
too much time
with um negative people
people who say i can't do something i
want to start myself with people who
want to do to do really cool stuff
who want to do passionate stuff creative
stuff who are very ambitious i love
spending
time with people like that and i love
people who
um can talk openly about anything the
deeper the conversation the better
otherwise it's just you might as well be
a
uh a um what's the word
it it's oh shoot what's the word it's
not a friend
it's like someone you know uh a uh
this is bad
like you're associated with them but
you're not really friends and someone
you're like hey what's up hey how's it
going
small talk small talk all right see you
later like there's no depth there you
know
so i don't know okay anyway let's get
through these uh
let's get out of here let's get through
the challenge winners guys so if you
don't know
well first off if you're not subscribed
i looked at the freaking thing
all right and it said like what is it
like 90 of people that watch
my videos are not subscribed so if you
guys aren't subscribed right now
subscribe to the channel if you're
enjoying this and you want more of this
i do this every single week all right i
stream cinema 4d
education every week um and try and help
you guys out
try and help you guys along and learn as
much together as possible
subscribe please it helps me a lot and
leave a comment about what you liked
about the video
what you think i could do better how
could i improve or ask me some more
questions
i'll answer more questions in the
comments all right so just
ask your questions in the comments i got
you i'll go through it
but um for those of you who don't know i
have a discord server
uh it's called learning with clint and
it's a great place for you guys to
join a community of passionate people
who
are eager to learn as much as possible
and are willing to help you learn
as well all right so the link to that
should be in the description as well
um and every single week at the end of
these live streams i announce
the winners of the weekly challenge that
i hold and then i issue a new challenge
every single week all right
so let's do it let's talk about the the
challenge winners
the prompt was um
what was it like clandestine technology
or something like that
old school technology i forget
what was it clandestine technology is
kind of the uh the vibe
but let me just double check let me hop
in here to the discord
um let's see
[Music]
create with clint all right submissions
weekly challenge vintage technology
that's what it was
so what i have here i've actually saved
out
all of the images we're going to go
through them all take a look and choose
the top five winners
so let me open pure f
and close uh
let me bring my head down
sweet okay
and then let me drop in all of
the submissions we had a lot
dude
look at all these
that is awesome all right i gotta learn
how to use pureref
here we go all right so i'm just gonna
go through and i'm gonna start breaking
these off
into like um
i'll go through every one and i'll move
them off into a little section okay
so it looks like we have an image here
by artifact this is an old phone
this is cool i like how you want black
and white with it i like your lighting
i think you could use some surface
imperfections on this
render um
your composition is not bad you know
it's just an old phone sitting on the
ground here
maybe this guy could be standing up or
something it'd be a little easier to see
what it is
but yeah certainly the surface
imperfections are lacking a little bit
it's too clean
uh it needs some smudges maybe some
scratches and stuff
but i like your lighting i think it's
good um so i'll
i'll move this to this pile i don't know
what that pile is but it's over here
this guy here this is from adam p98
all right and you did a typewriter this
is pretty sweet
um i like your lighting i think you're
i think you're lacking detail in this
like there could be a lot more stuff on
this desk
um it would be really cool if like
there's a bunch of stuff on the desk and
the typewriter was the focus
your light is kind of half shining on
the typewriter and the paper so i don't
really know where to look
this side of the frame has a lot of
activity and there's just a lot of dead
space on this side
and it is pretty dark so composition
wise i think can be improved a little
bit maybe
by adding more things putting more time
into it
this is maybe the situation where we
talked about doing like that weekly
challenge or
or the daily challenge versus like
spending a month or two on something
you could put more work into this guy um
not to say that your work is bad
because your typewriter is actually
really really nice and your lighting is
good and the papers look nice i think
it's just
composition and you have a really sad
love letter here
that's rough i will also put this over
here
next we have i think this is blaster let
me just be
sure oh sharp aluminum flavor this is an
old photo
of your dad he was a
tv and radio like builder i guess and
you try to recreate the photo i would
love to see that photo
but this is awesome dude this is what
i'm talking about like this is all the
detail going in here
a lot of detail in here super nice you
got your m ms
package your lighting is great i love
the top lighting
the person definitely looks waxy um
people are hard it's why i don't do
people
or i don't really include close-ups of
people in my renders because that's just
it's really hard to make look realistic
but i think you did a really good job
here man this is awesome
very sentimental this is your dad um an
old photo of your dad you got the film
green going this is really good
i like this a lot i'm going to move this
over
here on this side next up
we have an image by
who is this
perry hellion perry hellion all right so
this is cool man this is an asset this
is just like an asset here
that you created of this radio um
nice surface imperfections you got your
scratches and smudges super cool
it's just lacking um any sort of like
scene or story it's just the thing you
know
it's just the thing sitting on a table
very similar to the typewriter
it's not bad i think it just maybe is a
little bit more story
it can be filled in a little bit more
in terms of your asset i think it rocks
man you beveled your edges
that's great you got your surface
imperfections give it maybe denoise it a
little bit or a couple more samples
because i can see those fireflies
set your gi clamp to one if you are in
octane um for your octane settings
but yeah i love this dude this is super
cool
i'm gonna put this in this area right
here
next up we have this awesome
game boy i this this speaks to me
because i have
a very soft spot uh in my heart for
for uh for nintendo actually and the
game boy
the game boy color was my first system
this is by
frost foska frascillatro
um freaking awesome dude i love this
like i'm i can't recall if the a and b
buttons had the a and b indented into
them
but i love how you have like
the text is faded away i love that this
is
really really well done this is such a
good render
oh that's a good one man i'm gonna put
that
let's see i'll put that
here as well
next up we have this image by chuck 4d
this is
a old film camera super nice
it again is just an asset sitting on a
table but
it's a really nice close-up um like you
have your
video co-pilot smudged lens thing going
a little bit of film grain in here um
and it's just a really detailed model i
like this a whole lot
um very well done you got your surface
imperfections and your scratches and
stuff this is awesome
i'm also going to put this
into this pot right here
um next
up we have an image by rich
and this looks like an old computer
thing typewriter thing i'm not really
sure there's a gun over here randomly
um yeah a situation where it's just a
thing sitting on the table
not bad i think composition can be more
focused you don't need the gun i think
you can get closer to this
um and it looks like camo almost like
the
the the surface imperfections are a bit
too uniform
and then the keys are a bit too clean
but this isn't bad man this isn't bad
none of these
are actually bad which is the coolest
part i'm gonna put this
over let's see let's do this this
this let's do that
all right now these two are very similar
this is cool so this one is by um david
katz very nice
cool little computer room this isn't bad
not bad at all like there's a lot of
detail that went into this
um i feel like the floor is lacking a
couple things it's a little empty
but your lighting is really nice i like
how i like your yeah the lighting is
really good um your ceiling is all
broken up that's cool
you have some detail over here with the
circuit breakers this is really good
i'm going to put this where should this
go
maybe goes here i don't quite know what
these piles are for yet but
we'll figure it out
everyone say happy birthday to kim it's
her birthday today
she's waving from the side here's
gilbert
all right i'm almost done we're going
over all the submissions
and then we're going to enjoy a birthday
all right
this image here is by lucas t
also really cool you got your wall of
tvs
with your little foreground subject and
some grass it's pretty sweet
not much to say about this this is cool
i'm gonna put this in
oh a space bar that's a good ah man i'm
all over the place in this program i
need to learn it
i'll put this here as well
all right this image here i love all
right this is by
mdk um
so well done just a beautiful render and
it's presented in a very nice way uh
it's on your old polaroid and there's
actually a boss town too
reference in there that's hilarious i
don't know what
i don't know what these ones are i
hadn't figured that out yet
but yeah this is incredible your
lighting is so good your model's so good
your presentation is so good
i'm gonna sneak this over here
next up we got this image here this is
by
blaster jacks of your old uh
what do you call this something phone
it's a record player blasted out through
this giant speaker um
all right so yeah the first thing i feel
like it's uh it's just lacking
a bit of detail like what room is this
where is this
um the lighting it's a bit faded
it looks like um and i can see
i can see the actual like polygons in
here
right you can smooth this out you can
actually thicken
up this little trumpet piece and smooth
it out
yeah your uvs here are a little off so
you definitely want to make sure that
your smoothing and everything is correct
and make sure your normals are facing
the right way
i would fill out this bookshelf
put like you need to texture your walls
and your floor
certainly
but i know that for a lot of you guys
you actually said this is your first
time
entering the contest and you've been
working in 3d for like three months so
the fact that you guys are actually
doing the work and putting the stuff in
super proud of you guys so do not stop
do not get discouraged this just needs
more time that's it it just needs more
time
so um
who again a blaster yeah just keep it up
man
keep it up i'm gonna move this one
on over here all right next we have this
image here
by mr su-yog
this is really cool i dig this a lot
uh technology is the campfire around
which we tell our stories
yeah i love all the detail you have in
here this is what i'm talking about you
filled it with stuff
this is like someone's workspace uh you
got your hat you got your
little telescope your glasses old film
cameras large format medium format
cameras all the all the the shots up
here it looks we got some chromatic
admiration we got some foam grain this
is nice dude
this is really nice i'm gonna put this
over here
all right more games draycon 12 355.
this one's sick man i love this uh
this just has a soft place in my heart
very nice okay so i think your
background is way too saturated
um and it's too bright i think you can
take down the background and keep the
brightness
focused on the uh the nes here
love the surface imperfections on the
glass right here
um
and it looks like you have some
subsurface scattering in the plastic
here super cool
yeah i i would just focus your light on
the nintendo
take it down in the background reduce
your contrast or
reduce your saturation in the background
it's too too much too intense
i'm gonna put this one here solid work
i don't know is it here maybe i'll put
it there i'll put it there
all right cyberpunk 2017. this is super
cool i love this um this is by
eric bowers and
his son did the pixel art on the screen
here
super cool backstory on that yeah this
is sick man i love this idea
it's like a new game but put into an old
school
style cabinet i mean dude great work
this is a solid asset like i would
i'd play this for sure yeah you got some
nice volumetric fog coming in you got
your
cigarettes down here i love this i just
feel like you could have
you could have probably like duplicated
this and put it one over here and one
to the right and left and right of it oh
we have your coins across here too
that's nice
yeah if you if you like i feel like you
just need to fill out the scene a little
bit more
i suppose it's just a dark room or if it
was like sitting on the carpet of an
abandoned
um arcade that would have been sick
but the asset itself is killer dude
super killer i love this i'm gonna put
this
right here next we got one from uh
who is this i know this is ice cream
paint job doing
constant good work this is the cat
assault you came up with your own
uh vintage technology i love this it
catapults the salt and pepper
right into your hand why even why grab
the salt and pepper why pass the salt
and pepper if you could just catapult it
this is uh this is fun man like you
invented your own thing
that that's great that's freaking huge
love it and your renders are always nice
really really nice i'll put this over
here
next we have this like max uh but this
is my maximum
it's ramen with a telephone
in it i don't quite know
um this is good though i like your uh
your telephone
model is good you got your service
imperfection going
really nice right in here your noodles
are a bit
lackluster like the noodles are hard man
i'm gonna be honest with you
noodles are hard we did a ramen
challenge and most people got the
noodles wrong
um or or rather
most people got the didn't quite get the
noodles looking as realistic as possible
they're very tough very tough
but i like i do like your lighting
here and i like how it's on against the
psych which is this like
infinite backdrop of color if you're
gonna do
a single object without anything else in
the scene
i feel like this is the best way to go
um against the psych
so this is this is good man i'm gonna
put this
i'll put this on on this side
next we have an image by uh god
9005 or just god
this is cool yeah super cool it's a room
volumetric fog coming in
you got some stuff going on um framing
could
i think could tilt down a little bit
maybe
back out a little bit if this is a 35
you could probably go
25 and tilt down a hair
i think this just needs more detail if
you're gonna do a whole room
you need more detail you got to bevel
your edges always bevel your edges here
set your texture to box if you're in c4d
because it's wrapping around the sides
irregularly here
up your samples set your gi clamp to one
get you'll get rid of those fireflies
i love the surface imperfections on the
tv very nice i wonder if that's from
model haven uh they got some good stuff
you got your library this is this is
good
um volumetric fog sick
good work i'll put this here
next we got this gas pump by joey masti
joey masti the gas pump is
awesome the ground it's sitting on
i feel like it's clipped you're clipping
on the ground here
your rocks you have a yellow rock and
orange rock like these rocks i can tell
we're just kind of placed back here
and your ground texture it just needs
more to it it needs some shrubs and
stuff
just more detail your mountains aren't
bad
your sky is not bad i like the film
grain that you added
um the mountains do feel like they're
close and small
i would really push those back there and
scale them up
but again if you're going to do an
outdoor environment like this
you're kind of setting yourself up for a
lot of work because you have to detail
all this stuff to make it look legit
um but i love this model here is really
good minus this little like
polygon little broken piece here not bad
but hey man
good work i'll put this right here
next we have this vehicle by uh
who is this layout helisa
um yeah this is cool design cool design
for a vehicle
again just needs more work you need to
bevel your edges
you need to work on your surface
imperfections and not make it as uniform
you need to add more detail add more
geometric detail your wheels are
probably
too skinny they need thicker treads your
ground certainly needs a bit more work
you could scale down your texture i
believe
or find another texture it's a little
low poly it's a little low poly
um
[Music]
but i love the idea it's very like simon
stalin keep going with this just keep
keep working on this again i know a lot
of you guys had just entered this
contest for the first time
um after doing 3d for like three or four
months which is very very impressive
so please keep it up let's put this guy
over here next we have a walkman
by edward um this is super cool
i don't know what's on the screen i
really don't know what's on the screen
uh is that a nuclear blast or is that
an x-ray reading of a pregnancy i cannot
tell
um good job getting the headphone
foam like smushed down on the bottom
that's a good detail
again if you're gonna do just an image
of one thing
it's against the psych a solid color
background it feels
like you don't have to add all that
detail in um you're not setting yourself
up for a headache so this is good
i like this a lot um
yeah this is this is good solid work
i'll put this right here
ah this is great this is by um who is
this by
sitter
cool story i like the story and there's
an octane logo on the tv
and you got a skeleton i've been working
too hard too much starbucks
there's just money just money coffee
cups
i like your story i like your
presentation
this is good yeah this is awesome i like
your lighting
you got the magenta green opposing
colors
going on very nice
heck yeah not much more to say about
that i like it
other than bevel your edges please bevel
your edges
it'll catch the light this is by
who is this by jack
christensen yeah i think you've won some
of these
this is good man it's an environment
this is a full-on environment so i've
been playing a lot of last of us
recently and they
constantly are cutting holes in the
ceiling to let light shine down
i feel like you can let more light shine
down jack
um yeah your emissive here i think could
be
maybe a little brighter or you could
take away that noise that you have
inside
it's a little fuzzy um
your glass is a little thick you need to
bevel your edges here
on the door frame you got to bevel those
edges and i think again
you're going for a wide angle view of an
environment of an interior room
you're setting yourself up for a lot of
work it's suffering from
a lack of detail it needs more detail
you need stuff on the walls you need
more stuff you just need to fill it with
more stuff
this bottle is floating in the air why
um yeah you need more stuff need more
stuff
all right this one here this is like a
flying machine
so you have like the wings here the
wings here this little thing in the back
um and this is by uh mr
echo david davinci flying machine okay
i couldn't tell what this was at first
so i think the biggest issue with this
render is that it needs a different
angle you need to film it from
or shoot it from a different angle or
zoom out or something um
because it's very hard to tell what this
is and again it's kind of suffering from
like
an object sitting on just the ground
here
and it feels like there needs to be more
stuff in the environment
however i think this is really cool
i think this this uh
this asset you've created is super cool
it just needs to be presented
in a different way or if you're going to
put it into an environment it needs to
be filled out the environment needs to
be filled out again
setting yourself up for a lot of work
when you're putting it into an
environment because now you have to put
together this whole environment that
looks real so that you could
present your one thing you know like
figure out a different way like if it's
not up against the psych maybe it's just
in the corner of a barn or something
but this is not bad which hey corner of
a barn
you kind of did that you just need to
work on your ground it's a little too
uniform add some barrels you know
i think you get the idea um we have
we're almost done
we only have like eight more i'll try
and get through these paul this is your
render solid asset dude 10 out of 10
asset
this is awesome like i could see this on
modelhaven.com no problem
uh fantastic
kind of dealing with the same problem
you know it's sitting um
it's just the object sitting in an
environment i think it just needs more
of that environment you have some maps
you did a good job on that
you have a wall um but i feel like
there'd just be more detail
that could kind of go into this um but
the the
the technology itself dude is solid i
really like i don't know what this thing
is but it is
it looks really cool i'm gonna put it
over here
next we have a tv by paul
um another paul um
and hey you beveled your edges great
work
you beveled your edges yes you see how
it catches the light
yeah good work super good work um
set your ga clamp to one if you're in
octane you get rid of those fireflies
um i think you need surface
imperfections you need smudges you need
scratches
and it needs to be presented in a
certain way not just floating in the air
against hdri
but i think this is cool good work good
work
we have this brain thing i don't know
what this is
but this is by uh
who is this by where are you
why can't i not oh uh jay's monster
i don't know what this thing is dude it
said it in the description
i was saving out all the images didn't
have time because i was like running
down to the last minute but
this is craziness uh good detail work
really really good detail work on here
solid detail work you just need more
surface imperfections on these nails
and i think it needs um you see the
reflecting black
i know that grayscale gorilla has a
metal
hdri pack that like
allows metal to look really nice against
black because it's lit from
all these different lights it's
reflecting black so it's just
giving you back black which doesn't look
as good
but this is cool very interesting still
don't know what it is but
interesting put this over here we have a
radio
super solid asset i love it um it looks
actually a little low poly but it's not
bad man like this is really cool this is
by
who is this by
um no drama llama
yeah man this is cool i dig this i could
totally see this in a video game
very nice you have some like
anti-aliasing going on here
definitely get rid of that um
maybe a couple more surface
imperfections it's a little like blurry
it feels low poly and blurry to me
like a like a game asset you'd find in
the corner or something
um i see you kind of went for that psych
presentation meaning a psych is
a backdrop of a certain color that ramps
up in the back so it looks infinite
i think you can probably use a different
color um
but man this is this is cool i love your
colors and i love that you like probably
referenced something and
built this out so that's solid
um we have a film camera by
where are you at this is when i'm
starting to lose it
my brain points oliver hawk that's by
oliver hawk
super cool film camera um you got your
super 8 film
down here yeah this is nice
again you're in a situation where you
know you try to put it in the
environment
and you want to fill out the environment
i just don't know where this is or what
this would be
it looks like some a bench of some sort
but it looks a little empty i feel like
you can crop in like you want to crop
into like here or something
you know there's no reason to keep it so
wide you can even crop in
to like here or something and render it
from here
um but yeah you got the spider webs
going this is super cool
i think you did a really good job you
got your surface imperfections you
modeled this really well
you textured it really well and you got
your details you have your manual and
your film and everything so this is good
this is really good just i think it can
really benefit from a re-crop
i'll put this over here
next we have this image
by
sec
[Music]
this just reminds me of the matrix when
they're in the
in the nebuchadnezzar going through the
underground tunnels
but i feel like it's lacking in detail
and i don't quite know what this is or
where they're going
or who like is that yeah that looks like
a cigarette
which is cool that's a cool addition
but i'm missing a little bit of a little
bit more story
a little bit more context um and i think
it could use a bit more
detail and i think you can actually
shift your angle to
you can probably work on your
composition maybe centering this up
exactly frame center and having these
chairs on
a symmetrical left and right side of the
frame
i think would be cool but this isn't bad
keep it up
certainly keep it up
all right why can't i not what did i do
did i lock something
i think i locked something i don't know
how i did that
shoot i don't know okay we're just going
to roll with it like this i guess
we got this one here next this is by
yoshi
love it you got you got my skull up on
here
freaking crazy um some glasses
that's awesome some floppy disks
rains and whatnot i like this a lot this
is really cool i think you can um
up your samples probably maybe a little
less film grain it just feels a little
fuzzy
and i think you can probably light it a
little bit like you can add some
different lights maybe in the background
i know that you're trying to probably
hide the background
because there's no detail back there but
i'm kind of losing this computer monitor
and the focus is kind of let's see my
focus goes here immediately
and then it comes here and then it'll
stray over here and look down this way
um and kind of comes back around so not
bad i think you could crop this
again to something like
yikes
um dang it how do i full screen this
thing
canvas uh
control f okay
yeah that's not bad man that's not bad
at all um
three more and then we'll announce these
winners i know we've been going for a
while huh
let's see this is by
it's getting harder and harder now okay
this is by siranch
and i confirmed you had only done
3d for three months and you said this
looked way cooler in your head
all good man you did a really good job
keep going okay
keep it up make sure you bevel your
edges
i like the painterly kind of luck you
went on um you went for
because you're trying to break it up a
little bit i can see what you're doing
really cool um it just needs more detail
keep adding that detail your lighting
is fine okay give this actual glass here
and maybe just switch out this
background for
a couple more trees as opposed to just
one tree right in your face
um yeah it just needs more detail and
more time keep it up man
keep it up make sure your edges are
beveled right here
get some shelves goings and get some
pictures going keep working on it um
and keep it up don't stop don't get
discouraged all right this is really
good
second to last we have a floppy disk a
really detailed floppy disk this is like
when you're playing
resident evil 2 remake you open up an
item and you like look around you look
at it
or like in the last of us too you pick
up an item and you look at it this is
top notch really really nice asset it's
just
an asset against black though um versus
it being integrated into an environment
or
sticking out sticking out from a
computer or something but this is by uh
kitty cat candy really good work super
solid render
and finally we have the film camera but
by breech get those samples up get your
ga clamp to one get rid of those
fireflies
um not bad i think the composition can
be a little bit better
your focus is really shallow really
intense
but so it's hard to kind of it's hard to
see the object
but i think all-in-all is pretty good
man
not bad at all let's take a look at all
the renders
so i'm feeling like these
all of these here in the middle
ha are like a really really good asset
or a really good scene
um but they're lacking something whether
they're lacking detail in a background
or whether they're lacking like uh
some of them aren't even lacking
anything like this is just good you know
this is nice
um this one needs the surface
imperfections these two are amazing i
love this so much
and this guy here so this is gonna be
hard this is gonna be difficult this is
such a good asset i think it just needs
more context um
you know same here this is a solid asset
it just needs more detail in the
background
same for these guys down here these guys
i feel like need a bit more detail in
the asset itself
um or in the way it's presented
you know here like this just needs this
just needs more work like solid idea
solid concept if you just need to build
it out a bit more
um you know this one here difficult to
tell what it is
needs a bit um needs a bit more here
with the lighting and the hdri that
you're using
um this one here missing some surface
imperfections
missing some context missing an
environment that it's sitting
you know this one here a solid asset
but no story you know or anything
uh you know the background is up against
okay
it just needs a bit more work that's all
same for these guys
so that comes i mean this is this is
definitely a winner
this is certainly a winner um
so i'm gonna put that i'll put that over
here i can't move it anymore jeez what
the heck
this is a winner for me 100 winner
like the detail everything about this is
great the presentation the story
um the texturing the lighting so good
so so good
now we have this which is cool
the fact that you came up with your own
thing is awesome and not only did you
come up with your own thing
you rendered it and textured it and lit
it perfectly and presented it perfectly
so i'm pretty sure this is a winner here
this guy is really good this is an
example of
lots of stuff in the frame lots of
detail look at the book
the car the photos the pen the glasses
really really nice i think it could just
be a little bit brighter the lighting
can be a little bit
a little bit brighter but i'm definitely
considering this as a winner
um for now unless something over here
comes in and i like it a little bit more
this guy here
is so close i'm this might be like this
this
might be just might be it's just that
background is so saturated
and i think you can tilt down a little
bit to focus more on the system
let's see if anything over here changes
my mind
like i love this and why can't i move
these things around
it's okay um
shoot i think these two the game boy
and the camera are like honorable
mentions because
i these are so like these assets are so
well done this looks so nice
but like compared to someone who made
their own thing
and rendered it and textured it in a
really nice way and integrated it
into like an old style ad like is really
nice
i think it just takes it one step above
and then the difference between this
and this this is just integrated well
it's integrated really well so
i think i have to give it up for these
five
right here guys this is it these are our
winners so congratulations to ice cream
paint job
for winning with your cat assault
congratulations to
um to sharp aluminum flavor i think this
is like your third win in a row
with this awesome image of your dad i'd
love to see the original film uh film
shot
congratulations to mr suyag i think
yeah mr suyog with this beautiful image
here
congratulations to
sorry i have to i'm like after i find
these there's there was a lot of
submissions
congratulations to mdk with this
beautiful
picture it'd be super cool to actually
print this out with a polaroid that
would be awesome and congratulations
to uh where are you
to dracon12355 all of you guys
are challenge winners this week thank
you so much for your hard work this was
a really awesome i think this might be
the most successful weekly challenge of
all time
i think it's had the most submissions
and i'm
really digging these final results so
guys
um big news
very big news and i can't
release all the news yet but myself
and nvidia and connected with p and y as
well
are teaming up and collaborating on
something really cool for you guys
okay so keep doing these weekly
challenges
keep stepping up your game because
there's going to be something big
coming around the corner very soon that
you do not
want to miss out on all right i promise
you do not want to miss out on
so stick around if you guys are not
subscribed subscribe to the channel
you won't regret it we got some cool
stuff coming along
i'm gonna do my surface imperfection
tutorial breaking down the whole thing
we're gonna make some ourselves um
so yeah if you die if you guys didn't
have if i didn't answer your
your comment or your question please
leave a comment down below i will answer
it
no problem and let's figure out this
last
uh not last
let's see this is my brain is dead at
the end of this thing let's figure out
the weekly challenge right now
i'm taking submissions what do you guys
think what should we do for the weekly
challenge go ahead and leave your ideas
thank you so much guys for sticking
around and hanging out
so cool to have you all um way to go
friggin way to go everyone's stuck in
i'm a check here for super chats
make sure to miss any nope we're good
we are all good my throat hurts after
these i've talked for so much
sweet that was a good one guys
that was a solid one
car i feel like no we've done car
characters not bad cinema
okay candy candy's not bad
evolver what's up chris thank you sir
appreciate you very very much
super solid thank you sir thank you
thank you environment oh environment you
guys want the hard ones
recreate a movie scene you guys want the
really hard ones a carnival
sounds hard dragon that sounds intense a
ufo
[Music]
looping animations interesting abstract
favorite food
large scale scene
product pack
ufo horror
so we've done cars already
volume metrics volumetrics would be
tough
something psychedelic water food
landscape how to
water lakes oceans aircraft candy game
environment city
[Music]
hmm
ancient architecture creature
creature could be interesting
space all right we did we did we did um
planets
movie scene sci-fi steampunk weapon
gadget
keep going guys keep going i'm we're
gonna figure out all right so creature i
like creature but i'm not gonna
call it yet jungle
corridor aquatic neon aquatic
aquatic that could be interesting
aquatic
or
creature
[Music]
hmm
hmm
plant or photogrammetry we did we did
potted plant in the
past
all right hey if you guys if if we were
to call it between creature and aquatic
what would you guys want what do you
think
deep sea creature
well i guess creature could be a deep
sea creature
aquatic lots of aquatic um let's see
okay aquatic aquatic creature quiet
okay it looks like aquatic is it all
right
aquatic here we go
this week's weekly challenge is aquatic
you guys
need to create some sort of scene
that uses that prompt the aquatic
aquatic prompt
don't just download a turbosquid model
slap it in and light it and call it done
create that model yourself the point is
to learn as much as you can this week
okay
so come up with something aquatic use
that to inspire you to create whatever
the heck you're feeling
deep inside your aquatic soul
um and follow the discord link down
below there's a you know you guys know
there's the discord server post it under
submissions
if you're still working on it post it
under submission work in progress
and you can discuss your submissions and
ask a lot of
you know good questions people people
help you out in the discord server so
aquatic don't forget it if you guys want
to look at the winners for this week
go ahead and take a look at the
challenge winner submission or
challenge winners i think is the name of
the server
um but hey guys i gotta run it's my
girlfriend's birthday
we're gonna go do some fun stuff so i'll
see you guys
next week and in the meantime
keep working on that aquatic submission
and uh yeah keep learning keep growing
let's learn and grow together
so i'll see you guys next time stay
healthy stay safe
peace